[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans parlement
hebdo l'émission qui revient sur les
temps forts de l'actuelle assemblée
nationale et au sénat
et pour commenter toute la semaine
passée encore très largement consacrée à
la question des retraites
notre invité est aujourd'hui constance
le grip bonjour à rejouer vous êtes
député l ère des hauts-de-seine et on va
commencer par votre portrait vous êtes
né constance le grip bonjour à chatou
dans les yvelines vous avez fait vos
études à paris et à strasbourg on voit
votre carte d'identité qui s'affiche car
l'identité sommaire en 2010 vous revenez
à strasbourg parce que vous êtes élue
députée européenne lorsque michel
barnier démissionne pour devenir
commissaire européen vous êtes réélu
lors des élections européennes de 2014
le marché intérieur l'europe n'ont pas
de secrets pour vous c'est votre
compétence mais sept ans après le
terrain européen vous êtes investis par
les républicains pour les législatives
de 2010 est vous êtes élu député à l'ère
des hauts-de-seine et vous êtes la seule
députée de l'opposition en juillet 2019
a voté pour la ratification de ce fameux
traité du ceta qui est un traité de
libre-échange qui a fait beaucoup de
controverses et finalement vous est
cohérente avec la ligne de votre parti
et vous est même la seule cohérente j'ai
envie de dire je suis cohérent d'abord
avec moi même avec mes convictions sur
ce sujet là je crois absolument
nécessaire que dans le contexte mondial
qui est le nôtre
les puissances occidentales arrive à
nouer des alliances sur le plan
économique ce au plan commercial sur le
plan des normes parce que nous voyons
bien que la géopolitique mondiale est
totalement bouleversée qu'émergent de
plus en plus et s'installent des forces
très conquérante en asie par exemple
pourquoi ne pas penser à la chine par
exemple et donc nous avons tout à fait
intérêt je pense nous les puissances
occidentales de part et d'autre de
l'atlantique par exemple à faire bloc
sur ce type de sujet voilà constance la
clé pour leurs vins notamment par les
politiques intérieures et parler de la
réforme des retraites a toujours à la
une
ce projet de loi arrive en conseil des
ministres d'ailleurs la semaine
prochaine le 24 janvier et à l'assemblée
début février et on évoquera cette
nouvelle proposition de loi pour lutter
contre les violences conjugales elle a
été votée à l'assemblée au coeur du
texte la possible levée du secret
professionnel des médecins en cas de
violences enfin la politique de la ville
grande oubliée des politiques publiques
c'est le constat fait par jean louis
borloo l'ex ministre de la ville réclame
une commission d' enquête sur le sujet
et on va commencer par le sujet à la une
la réforme des retraites
[Musique]
24 janvier présentation du texte en
conseil des ministres 3 mars vote du
texte à l'assemblée en première lecture
le gouvernement a donné le tempo du
débat à venir sur les retraites au
parlement l'opposition de droite comme
de gauche dénonce le calendrier la
méthode explications des positions avec
stéphanie des pierres avant même la
présentation en conseil des ministres
fin janvier le ton nom au palais bourbon
vous nous demandez de légiférer à
l'aveuglé sans connaître le coût des
mesures
c'est un déni de démocratie monsieur le
premier ministre
comment pouvez-vous demander aux députés
de voter la réforme des retraites sans
leur dire comment elle sera financée
les députés se pencheront sur le texte
en février c'est à dire avant la fin de
la conférence de financement entre
autres partenaires sociaux prévus en
avril
un calendrier qui ne plaît pas à
l'opposition
gauche et droite dénonce un coup de
force mais seront en train de délibérer
sans savoir pour finir ce qui sera
réellement décider et chasser je sais
pas dans quelle démocratie au monde
une pratique pareil existe où on
présente à un parlement un texte on le
fait voter dessus mais c'est pas
celui-là qui s'appliquera c'est en outre
la majorité
elle ne voit pas le problème le fait
qu'il y ait un décalage dans le temps
non induit en aucun cas un
appauvrissement et de la discussion sur
le l'essence de la réforme est ni même
la capacité du parlement opposition et
majorité confondues de modifier le texte
de l'amender de le débat de le discuter
je crois véritablement
que ceux qui essaient d'introduire le
doute sur le fait qu'il ya une sorte de
démarche parallèle le fonds avait une
très très très grande mauvaise foi
le calendrier n'est pas le seul motif de
mécontentement les oppositions dénonce
aussi le recours aux ordonnances pour
une partie de la réforme des retraites
constance le grip dans quel état
d'esprit êtes-vous à la proche de ce
débat dans l'hémicycle est ce que vous
êtes prêtes à travailler à la majorité
pour avec l'espoir d'améliorer ce projet
de loi qui va réformer les retraites
alors nous sommes toujours dans un état
d'esprit combatif et toujours ardemment
désireux d'exercer pleinement notre rôle
de législateur
c'est bien pour cette raison notamment
que le groupe l'est républicain son
président damien abad
l'une des vice présidentes de
l'assemblée nationale issue de nos rangs
annie genevard proteste vigoureusement
contre effectivement le calendrier et la
méthode il faut quand même que nos
compatriotes comprennent que si on ne
peut pas parler du volet recettes entre
guillemets c'est à dire la manière dont
sera dans le futur financer notre
système des retraites en tout cas
l'architecturé générale du projet tel
que l'exécutif le présente à travers ces
deux projets de loi exclut les modalités
de financement c'est comme si on parlait
me rendait vous allez devoir travailler
sur un texte à trous oui c'est un energy
grand blanc c'est tout à fait un texte à
trous en gros il ya le volet dépenses
n'ya pas le volet recettes en sell-in si
on discutait d'un budget avec uniquement
les dépenses mais pas les recettes tout
à fait bancal tout à fait déséquilibrer
il ya effectivement des trous et tout
cela n'est pas digne de l'institution
parlementaire n'est pas dit quand même
de ce que peut attendre dans une
démocratie parlementaire moderne qu'est
ce qui vous choque le plus le recours à
la procédure accélérée ou celui aux
ordonnances alors honnêtement le recours
à la procédure accélérée on a fini par
s'y habituer je ne dis pas que c'est
dans l'idéal forcément la méthode que
nous privilégions et que nous trouvons
absolument c'est qu'elles font la règle
a dit le premier vol entre il a dit ça
est il qu'à quasiment sur toutes les
réformes des retraites ces dernières
années en date et que voilà tout à fait
et voilà on est lucide et on connaît
cette histoire parlementaire là par
contre effectivement le fait qu'ils
aient quasiment un tiers des articles
des deux projets loi qui renvoient à des
ordonnances et le parlement donne
l'habilitation à l'exo pouvoir exécutif
les ordonnances exaucé constitution de
la vème république ce n'est pas
forcément dispositions de la
constitution
d'ailleurs qui m'avait le plus enjoué et
on sent bien que sur un sujet aussi
important que celui de la réforme des
retraites je rappelle que c'est un
montant global de dépenses de l'ordre de
320 milliards d'euros à l'heure où nous
parlons c'est 25 % de la dépense
publique le système des retraites donc
c'est quand même assez colossal se dire
qu'on renvoie cela que nous par le monde
nous des saisies sont en quelque sorte
de notre incapacité à légiférer et qu'en
plus on nous oblige à marche très fort
c'est de ne discuter que des grands
principes sans du tout savoir comment
tout le système va être équilibré va
être financée et parfaitement inédit et
de notre point de vue on vous sent
combative
est-ce que normand vous êtes d'accord
avec edouard philippe qui appellent à la
fin du mouvement qui estime aussi que
les mobilisations les grèves n'ont que
trop duré
il est clair que nous appelons à ce que
le bon sens l'emporté et à ce que les
mouvements sociaux qui ont fortement
contribué à perturber grandement la vie
des familles la vie de très nombreuses
franciliennes et franciliens qui
continuent à avoir pour certains une
véritable galère pouvoir se rendre à
leur travail et c'est que ces mouvements
sociaux là et que de ces perturbations
dans les transports publics franciliens
notamment parce que c'est là que se
focalisent voilà les derniers efforts
d'un sombre de deux syndicats se termine
effectivement je n'irai pas que voilà la
grève a trop duré je ne sais pas ce que
c'est une grève qui dure trop par
rapport une grève qui dira pas assez
mais force est de constater que les
faits le 5 décembre quand même la fête a
commencé
puisant pour beaucoup beaucoup de
familles et beaucoup beaucoup de
travailleurs partement dans notre région
et qu'il y ait un coût économique aussi
il faut le dire notamment dans les
centres villes notamment en région
parisienne notamment à paris pour les
commerçants les petits artisans toute
une série de petites entreprises donc ça
ça commence à peser très lourd alors on
l'a dit le calendrier la méthode suivie
dans cet examen du projet de loi
retraites est contesté aussi bien
à droite qu'à gauche est-ce que vous
pensez que cette union d d opposition si
je puis dire peut changer la donne peut
influer sur le débat ou pas alors union
des oppositions sur le fond ils sont
bien des sujets nous ne partageons pas
du tout les vues de la france insoumise
mes amis c'est vrai que la manière dont
elle est menée
oui mais ça a pu arriver là dessus je
souhaite être clair nous ne partageons
pas du tout les positions de la france a
soumises ou les partis communistes sur
la réforme des retraites
il ya effectivement en termes de méthode
et d'irrespect de l'institution
parlementaire de ce moment ça envoie la
paix que nous partageons pour le coup ça
ne veut pas dire que nous allons nous
associer donc je ne sais quelle saveur
généraux mais pas nous allons avoir
forcément des amendements très
différents les uns et les autres à nous
nous serons cohérents politiquement en
fonction de ce que nous posons est ce
que ça peut changer la donne ce nous
espérons qu effectivement et c'est ce
qu'a écrit damien abad très précisément
dans le courrier qu'il a adressé au nom
du groupe l'est républicain au premier
ministre nous souhaitons un autre
calendrier que notamment la conférence
des présidents ne se déroule pas dans
une espèce la conférence des finances
dans une espèce de démarches parallèles
dont le parlement n'a rien à connaître
on va continuer à parler de la réforme
des retraites avec edouard philippe qui
a abandonné provisoirement l'âge pivot
il a lâché du lest on se rappelle bien
sûr le week-end dernier mais pas l'âge
d'équilibré il l'a d'ailleurs confirmé
par des questions d'actualité au sénat
en l'écoutant
nous voulons créer la shd équilibre de
façon à inciter nos concitoyens à
travailler c'est vrai c'est vrai plus
longtemps de façon c'est vrai à
équilibrer le système de retraite par
répartition
ça n'est ni un gros mot ni un scandale
c'est ce qui se passe dans tous les pays
du monde
voilà étant philippe il a lâché sur
l'âge pivot mais pas sur l'âge
d'équilibré qui reste dans le texte et
s'applique à partir de 2030 c'est parce
que ça vous rassure on sait que vous
voulez l'augmentation de l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite
mais ce maintien de l'âge d'être libre
sais pas si éloigné finalement ça n'est
pas si éloigné que cela est
effectivement jeu on sait tout à fait
auprès ministre d'être à ses yeux
cohérent depuis quelques temps dans son
expression au public lorsqu'il met
l'accent sur la nécessité d'équilibrer
le système de retraites et le système de
retraite par répartition auquel nous
sommes très attachés doit faire face à
de nouveaux défis démographiques sociaux
en fonction des évolutions du marché du
travail du nombre d'actifs par rapport
aux inactifs et cédera de ça il ya une
absolument nécessite effectivement de
financer ce système mais nous on manque
de financer justement comment vous le
fait alors nous nous avons contrairement
à ce déni de réalité qui a caractérisé
la campagne des macros en 2017 qui n'a
jamais parlé dans sa campagne et c'est
l'une des raisons c'est peut-être la
faute originelle qui fait que la parole
de l'exécutif n'est plus très crédible
et voilà nous avons toujours dit avec
courage ce n'est pas forcément
populaires je le conçois avec lucidité
qu'il fallait effectivement repoussé
l'âge légal du départ à la retraite
c'est ainsi qu'on finance les choses en
proposant progressivement à raison d'un
report d'un trimestre par an l'âge légal
du départ à la retraite on finance une
année gagner entre guillemets donc ça
rapporte 8 milliards d'euros donc nous
proposons en huit ans de repousser l'âge
légal du départ à la retraite à 64 ans à
65 ans éventuellement dont en 12 ans
mais à tout le moins l'objectif de 64
ans au bout de huit ans permet d'assurer
l'équilibré financier sans baisse des
pensions de retraite pour nous c'est
essentiel et sans hausse des cotisations
est traité du tout à fait voilà
essentiel également un mot constance le
grip sur cette tribune qui a été publiée
dans le monde part à 26 députés et
sénateurs et l'air à l'appel d'un député
julien aubert il dénonce l'abaissement
des cotisations sur les très hauts
revenus dans cette réforme et
l'affaiblissement du système par
répartition et il ya des craintes aussi
qu'on en a et sur un système par
capitalisation
c'est un peu le monde à l'envers que ce
soit allé l air qu'ils aillent sur ce
terrain dont je pense pas que ce soit le
monde à l'envers
nous avons toujours dit et tous les
gouvernements de droite et tous les
présents la république issu de nos rangs
qui se sont succédé ont toujours dit et
ont toujours maintenu et tout fait pour
sauver
je dirais échéance après échéance le
système de retraite par répartition je
rappelle que trois grandes réformes des
retraites et donc de ce système de
retraite paraît
partition basé sur le principe de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle ont été
effectués par la droite et on a permis à
chaque fois d'envisager l'avenir avec
lui seul un geste de kraft je comprends
que les craintes soit émise maintenant
il faut se garder de diaboliser
peut-être tel ou tel terme
kabila nation est un mot effectivement
qui fait peur parce qu'on pense de ce
torrent capitale entre guillemets
l'abandon du principe laquelle nous
sommes très attachés encore une fois qui
est fondamental dans notre système qui
est la retraite par répartition
quand on dit épargne retraite là tout de
suite on sent qu'il ya quelque chose de
plus positif
très sincèrement on reconnaît à nos
compatriotes
à l'heure actuelle beaucoup de bon sens
et beaucoup de sagesse parce que c'est
vrai les français et par n'y déjà pour
leur retraite très très lucidement les
français savent qu'ils ont besoin alors
à travers son de produits des pannes à
travers l'assurance vie à travers
peut-être l'acquisition d'une petite
propriété immobilière censé leur
apporter un petit complément de revenu
et qu' il peut être important de
construire de manière durable les
conditions d'avoir une retraite heureuse
donc méfions nous des mots qui font peur
mais en tout cas il est certain que nous
nous réaffirmerons avec beaucoup de
force notre attachement au système de
retraite par répartition et en attendant
le débat parlementaire sur cette réforme
des retraites on va parler de cette
proposition de loi qui a été examiné et
adopté en commission pour protéger les
victimes de violences conjugales
[Musique]
alors ce texte arrive moins de trois
semaines après la promulgation d'un
autre texte qui visait également à
lutter contre les violences conjugales
il est signé aurélien pradié votre goût
collègues et l'air eh bien cette fois le
texte est porté par la majorité avec une
mesure centrale la possibilité de lever
le secret professionnel explications de
fanny die face au décompte quasi
quotidiens des victimes de violences
conjugales
les députés souhaitent aller plus loin
avec une nouvelle proposition de loi en
commission l'essentiel du texte a fait
l'objet d'un large consensus
mais une mesure à diviser celle qui
prévoit la possibilité de lever le
secret professionnel des médecins en cas
de violence conjugale
une disposition qui suscite critiques et
inquiétudes aussi bien à gauche qu'à
droite
nous estimons que vraiment il ne faut
pas briser ce secret professionnel
d'abord parce que c'est le lien de
confiance qui se joue entre le médecin
et la patiente qui à mon avis va être
totalement mise à mal ne faut pas
infantiliser les femmes mais au
contraire leur donner les moyens de se
défendre et d'être actrices de leur
propre combat
ce que je ne voudrais pas qu'on brise le
lien de confiance qui existe aujourd'hui
sur le secret médical est ce qu'on
pourrait pas avancé plus sur cette
question avec les professionnels de
santé plutôt que détruire quelque chose
qui fait consensus entre les médecins et
la population face à ses doutes à ces
interrogations la rapporteur de la
proposition de loi bérengère couillard a
tenté de rassurer l'opposition la
rédaction qui vous est proposé comporte
des garanties déjà le médecin doit
s'efforcer autant que possible d'avoir
l'accord de la victime
à défaut d'accord la démarche est
communiquée à la victime et n'ai pas
réalisé donc dans son dos ensuite nous
précisons bien que le praticien al
intime conviction
ce qui est un mot très fort et peut-être
pas le plus adapté pour des juristes et
que la victime encourent un danger
immédiat
l'ordre des médecins a déjà indiqué
qu'il tenait cette expression pour
l'équivalent d'un danger vital
la victime va se faire tuer si personne
ne fait rien voilà la traduction
finalement adopté l'article la
proposition de loi seront débattues dans
l'hémicycle fin janvier à constance le
grip est ce que cette proposition de loi
qui arrive après l'adoption à
l'unanimité
et et de celle de votre collègue reliant
pradet est utile quelles sont ces
apports et bien il est toujours utile
d'essayer d'aller toujours plus loin
dans la lutte contre ce terrible fléau
que sont les violences conjugales les
violences intrafamiliales y avait
effectivement des dispositifs très très
important que la proposition de loi
portée par mon collègue aurélien pradié
est venue conforter élargir on il n'ya
pas mais on a à présent à l'esprit la
généralisation du bracelet anti
rapprochement la rapidité à laquelle les
ordonnances de protection pourront
maintenant être prononcée les mesures
également à titre expérimental mais très
forte sur l'axé on n'aurait pas pu faire
mais incertain après mûre efficace
nous aurions souhaité mais on a bien vu
que l'exécutif et la majorité alors que
se déroulait le processus dit du
grenelle sont les violences conjugales
ne voulait pas concéder à l'opposition
parlementaire tout une réforme d'ampleur
au niveau leur gré des lives alors il a
bien été tenté de faire d'ailleurs aussi
bien la soirée salle coco sénat plus sur
le véhicule législatif
porté par le groupe l'est républicain et
aurélien pradié mais on a bien senti que
du côté de la majorité parlementaire et
de l'exécutif et peut-être de la
secrétaire d'état en charge des droits
des femmes y avait une vraie volonté de
ne pas se voir en quelque sorte piquer
les bonnes idées je dis les choses que
par la nasa et voilà il fallait garder
des choses pour que l'exécutif et la
majorité lrm on est le le bénéfice bon
on va pas chipoter ce qui est le plus
important c'est le progressé et il faut
des mesures concrètes et nous seront
constructifs va parler de l'une des
mesures qui concentre les débats c'est
la levée du secret médical du secret
professionnel pour les médecins en cas
de danger vital c'est la mesure qui a
concentré les discussions à ce que vous
vous y être favorables oui j'y suis
favorable j'ai bien entendu les réserves
ont été exprimées par plusieurs membres
de ma famille politique a commencé à
brûler le bois y est tout à fait très
engagé sur ces sujets depuis de très
nombreuses
année qui continuera à porter ce sujet
dans le débat en séance publique
mais il me semble que la rédaction
actuelle est à ses yeux qu'à des crises
encadrent pose des garanties et
appartements ou l'ordre des médecins lui
même semble considérer que le texte
était juridiquement a à peu près
consolidé à peu près stabilisée moi je
n'y ai pas d'hostilité au contraire je
vois bien qu'il ya là quelque chose qui
peut véritablement et des signalements
gré ce texte
globalement on va voir si l'ensemble des
amendements que nous portons parce que
nous avons d'autres idées et nous allons
porter des amendements encore une fois
comme je le disais nous on est très
constructif dans cette discussion à
l'assemblée nationale en séance publique
mais si nos amendements sur d'autres
sujets sont sont acceptées nous
considérons que nous aurons globalement
fait oeuvre utile encore une fois un mot
sur les moyens du gouvernement sur la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes sont ils à la hauteur certains
députés dénoncent l' immense supercherie
des moyens annoncés alors il ya
effectivement une petite querelle de
chiffres quant aux moyens donnés à un
sombre d'associations je veux pas
forcément rentrer dans cette querelle de
chiffres parce que je suis pas je vous
le dis comme je le pense profondément
convaincu que c'est l'amoncellement de
dépenses publiques qui règle tous les
problèmes dans une société comme la
société française je crois beaucoup plus
aux mesures législatives bien sûr qu'ils
peuvent venir modifier le cours des
choses donner plus de force à des
processus judiciaires donner plus de
possibilités à son d'organismes publics
pour prévenir les voilà tout à fait il
ya des changements de mentalité énorme
qu'il faut continuer à accompagner dont
les services des forces de l'ordre par
exemple police et gendarmerie
tout cela ça va bien au delà d'une
querelle de chiffres est les derniers
thèmes de cette émission la politique de
la ville au coeur de l'audition de
jean-louis borloo au sénat
[Musique]
rappelons que l'ancien ministre de la
ville a aussi été l'auteur d'un rapport
sur les quartiers prioritaires qui a été
enterré par l'exécutif au sénat il a
réclamé une enquête pour comprendre
pourquoi la rénovation urbaine est
aujourd'hui à l'arrêt c'est un accueil
plus que chaleureux
je ne sais pas s'il est à vous manque
mais vous manquez à la république que
jean louis borloo a reçu de la
commission des affaires économiques du
sénat tous bords politiques confondus
l'ancien ministre de la ville est
considéré comme le père de la rénovation
urbaine lui retirait de la vie politique
depuis 2014 a tout de même rappelé je ne
suis pas dans un agenda politique et je
viens comme citoyen parler à des
citoyens en charge pendant deux heures
il s'est gardé de critiquer tel ou tel
gouvernement mais s'est indigné d'après
lui les programmes de réhabilitation des
quartiers sensibles sont à l'arrêt
totalement athée pas réduit de 30% par
diviser par 2 pas diviser par quatre
arrêtés
comment un dispositif une ambition voté
à l'unanimité des sénatrices et
sénateurs
comment cette décision de la nation
française at elle pu s'arrêter sans que
personne ne l'ait jamais décidé il
demande une enquête parlementaire sur la
question
ils accusent la bureaucratie et le
ministère des finances d'avoir pris le
pas sur la dynamique de projet jean
louis borloo qui a aussi été interrogé
sur son plan banlieue remis à l'exécutif
en avril 2018 est balayée dans la foulée
pourquoi ne vous a pas écoutés au faux
j'en sais rien ça va se faire
julien normandie essaie de faire en
filigrane il en appelle à plus
d'initiatives pour les banlieues qui
sont d'après lui l'une des réserves de
croissance de la france pays
économiquement à maturité mais un
reportage d'aude révue états constance
le grip est ce qu'il faut pour vous une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire comme
le réclame jean louis borloo pour
comprendre comment et pourquoi la
rénovation urbaine s'est arrêté je suis
pas sûr que l'instrument commission
denquête parlement
r soit l'instrument le plus approprié il
ya des moyens de recherche et
d'investigation qui appartiennent aux
différentes commissions parlementaires
commission des affaires économiques
commission des affaires sociales il ya
des choses voilà on a des délégations
aux collectivités territoriales et donc
on peut certainement dans la foulée du
cri d' alerte est lancée par jean louis
borloo aussi sur les rangs dans le
constat qu'il fait au fond que la
politique de la ville et l'un des angles
morts de l'exécutif
il ya eu leur absolue mans il faut
donner à un rôle et bordeaux le crédit
effectivement d'avoir non seulement
porté toute cette politique de
rénovation urbaine avec énormément de
conviction et d'efficacité mais aussi de
continuer à être extrêmement lucide est
effectivement un ensemble de choses se
sont arrêtés ou se sont essoufflés mais
la politique et de la vie politique de
la ville digne de ce nom qui de notre
point de vue vivement est absente et
assez largement absent des
préoccupations de l'actuel exécutif ça
n'est pas uniquement encore une fois de
l'argent public dépensé la rénovation
urbaine même s'il faut également penser
aux aspects budgétaires et financiers
d'une politique alors nous nous avons
par exemple lors de nos journées
parlementaires à belfort le groupe l'est
républicain de l'assemblée nationale
sorti une vingtaine de propositions pour
une politique de la ville digne de ce
nom parce que nous avions identifiés
qu'effectivement la fracture
territoriale s'était pas uniquement
entre la france des villes et la france
des campagnes s'était également les
banlieues qui avait disparu des écrans
sassard propositions sont là des
propositions en matière de logement on a
des propositions en matière de mise en
place de dispositif spécifique pour
lutter contre le chômage qui frappe
beaucoup plus dans les quartiers
difficiles les banlieues que partout
ailleurs sur l'importance d'investir
dans vos intentions
oui tout à fait également en matière de
restauration de l'autorité de l'état
donc on a toutes une vision appuyé sur
gérer ces trois piliers là effectivement
logement lutte contre le chômage de mars
et et formation et puis restauration de
l'autorité de l'état qui fondent ce que
nous considérons comme être une
politique indispensable une politique de
la ville
moderne et adaptée aux défis
d'aujourd'hui et bien ce sera le mot de
la fin merci constance le grip d'avoir
été notre invité merci à tous d'avoir
suivi cette émission et à la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]